[Música]
Afganistán vuelve a estar en la mira de
la comunidad internacional esta vez a
raíz de esa Ronda de conversaciones
lideradas por la ONU a la que asistieron
25 estados miembros de esta organización
internacional el objetivo de este
encuentro a Puerta cerrada y en el
máximo secretismo fue dialogar sobre la
situación de Afganistán y ver cómo la
comunidad internacional se puede
relacionar con el gobierno del talibán y
con este país asiático Cuáles son
Entonces los temas que preocupan con
respecto a la situación que está
viviendo Afganistán pues primero las
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
también la situación de las mujeres
afganas tema que hemos tratado aquí en
France 24 también el terrorismo el
tráfico de drogas y por supuesto
preocupa en general el futuro político y
social que puede tener este país
hay que decir que este grupo no fue
convocado a este encuentro estamos
hablando del grupo talibán Cuál sería la
razón pues la ONU dice que no reconoce
al talibán como representante del
gobierno de Afganistán sin embargo qué
sentido tiene entonces excluirlos de
estas conversaciones si son quienes
están controlando el país en este
momento a pesar de esta posición el
secretario general de la ONU o el
portugués Antonio Gutiérrez se mostró
dispuesto a abrir una puerta de diálogo
con el talibán pero criticó la situación
de las mujeres afganas escuchemos
la prohibición actual de que las mujeres
afganas trabajen para las Naciones
Unidas y las ong internacionales y
nacionales es inaceptable y pone vidas
en peligro
permítanme ser claro como el cristal
nunca permaneceremos en silencio ante
los ataques sistémicos sin precedentes
contra los derechos de las mujeres y las
niñas
[Música]
cuando sea el momento adecuado para
hacerlo obviamente no rechazaré esa
posibilidad hoy no es el momento
adecuado para hacerlo
previo a este encuentro de la ONU los
representantes del grupo talibán
indicaron que esta reunión sin tenerlos
en cuenta pues era una reunión ineficaz
y contraproducente aclararon una cosa
son las problemáticas internas del país
y la otra es la ayuda internacional que
la ONU puede dar a Afganistán estas
fueron las declaraciones
no hay duda de que el emirato islámico
está dispuesto a tener interacciones
positivas con la comunidad internacional
pero una cosa que debemos dejar claro es
que los problemas sociales los problemas
internos del pueblo Afganistán no deben
asociarse con la ayuda humanitaria
compromiso reconocimiento y otras cosas
por el estilo y estas no deben usarse
como herramientas políticas
entonces preguntas sobre la mesa Pues
muchas comenzamos por mencionarles
solamente algunas era necesaria entonces
la presencia del talibán en este
encuentro para entender cuál es el norte
que el talibán le quiere dar Afganistán
un Norte con todos los peros y las
críticas de la comunidad internacional
Pero al menos poder entender que lo que
están buscando
teniendo la gobernanza de este país ese
intento de relacionamiento entre la
comunidad internacional la ONU y
Afganistán pasa por el reconocimiento
Internacional del talibán como un
gobierno legítimo una de las preguntas
que queda y también qué va a suceder
entonces con las mujeres afganas Qué
papel va a jugar en esta ecuación países
vecinos Como por ejemplo Pakistán y por
ejemplo china Cuál es el futuro que
tiene Afganistán con el talibán sin
tener un reconocimiento internacional
Pues todos estos temas los vamos a
analizar hoy en el debate y para
conversar sobre estos temas y algunas de
las preguntas que les he planteado hemos
invitado a Alejandro Álvarez él es
titular de la catedra de ciencia
política de la Universidad de Buenos
Aires se conecta justamente desde la
capital Argentina desde la ciudad de
Madrid en España se conecta Andrés de
Castro García subdirector del instituto
universitario general Gutiérrez mellado
y en el estudio de France 24 nos
acompaña Manuel rayán él es docente e
investigador de la facultad de finanzas
gobierno y relaciones internacionales de
la Universidad externado de Colombia los
tres les doy la bienvenida al programa
pero recuerden ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de este
debate pueden dejar sus preguntas y
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales estamos en Twitter en Facebook
en instagram nos encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 todo junto y a mí me
encuentran en Twitter como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos del programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Alejandro en la ciudad de Buenos Aires
Alejandro Gracias por estar con nosotros
en el debate en la noche de hoy y
pregunta de Punto de partida para el
debate tiene sentido o tuvo sentido este
encuentro esta reunión a Puerta cerrada
de la ONU sin tener a representantes del
talibán presentes
se entiende en parte por la falta de
reconocimiento como el gobierno legítimo
de Afganistán y esa es un poco lo que
dice el secretario general ahora bien la
pregunta que tenemos que hacernos es si
va a seguir Eternamente la ONU con este
estilo de puras palabras cuando en
realidad lo que se le está pidiendo lo
que se le está exigiendo es realizar
reuniones que tengan una conexión Más
directa con soluciones reales porque ni
las mujeres ni los niños de Afganistán
van a encontrar ningún alivio a su
situación con más reuniones lo que
debería hacerse y la lógica de la
negociación internacional indica Es que
así sea por un grupo ad hoc digamos de
países que No necesariamente este se
opongan el reconocimiento del gobierno
talibán iniciar un diálogo directo
porque si no va a ser imposible de
resolver esto se resuelve con diálogo
directo no preguntad
del Punto de partida también para Andrés
en la ciudad de Madrid Andrés Bienvenido
al programa Gracias por acompañarnos y
también cree usted que tiene sentido
este encuentro sin tener a los mayores
involucrados en todas las situaciones el
talibán
yo creo que este encuentro no tiene
sentido en general porque
llegar a lo que nosotros podríamos
entender desde occidente como una
solución pasa por tener el poder para
generar esa situación y evidentemente no
existe es por tanto que vemos que la ONU
no puede ofrecer esa solución real y en
el vídeo que hemos visto nos ha alejado
muy claro que no es el momento ahora
Pero puede ser que haya un momento
evidentemente seguimos todavía desde
occidente viendo el mundo con ese
discurso hegemónico liberal pero a la
vez perdiendo poder en el mundo Entonces
vemos que no se sostienen muchos de los
elementos que nos han permitido en las
últimas décadas analizar el mundo y
entonces evidentemente colapsa
y para terminar esta primera ronda aquí
en el estudio Manuel bienvenido Gracias
por acompañarnos la misma pregunta Usted
cree que estas reuniones estas
encuentros de la ONU tiene sentido sin
tener al talibán involucrado Santiago yo
comparto las opiniones de las dos
personas que me antecedieron y Creo yo
que hacer esta reunión lo que evidencia
es por el contrario quien occidente no
hay una posición conjunta porque aquí la
reunión era a ver cómo la comunidad
internacional que comúnmente es muy mal
utilizada llamada cierto que solamente
algunos países de occidente buscan es
unir unas posiciones pero eso a mí me
deja entonces la duda es quien occidente
no tienen la misma postura de cómo
tratar Afganistán y creo que no saben
por tres temas principalmente que lo que
hoy llama la atención nuevamente
Afganistán en el plan internacional uno
un tema económico como ustedes lo
mencionaba China y sus proyectos de
desarrollo en este país dos un tema de
derechos humanos con las mujeres y un
tercer elemento que que por ser el
último no deja de ser importante el tema
de seguridad y territorio países que han
jugado un papel clave en ello y que sí
reconocen digamos que al talibán es
Pakistán que ya ha tenido reuniones en
suelo de afgano pero también China y es
también Buscar cuales va a ser si china
va a ser el patrocinador de la
infraestructura que requiere Afganistán
y dos también todo el tema de las
tierras raras y el litio y Creo yo que
esta reunión apunta más a buscar una
coherencia dentro de occidente para
tratar Afganistán porque creo que pueden
haber disputas dentro del mismo
accidente en relación con Afganistán
hago la ronda la inversa continúa aquí
en el estudio con Manuel Entonces en ese
sentido de acuerdo a lo que ustedes
están planteando si hay un encuentro de
Antonio Gutiérrez como representante de
la ONU con algún representante de El
talibán eso ya da un indicio a un
reconocimiento entender que tiene que
establecer una mesa de diálogo Cómo se
entiende ese Punto de partida yo no creo
que sea perse un reconocimiento
internacional pero sí creo que me envía
el mensaje que sí o sí para tratar el
tema afgano Tiene que hablar con el
talibán no hay otra opción
hoy el talibán tiene control de todos
los puntos de control territorial de
Allí es donde ingresan la mayoría a
través de impuestos de importaciones es
el talibán entonces Creo yo que hacerlo
con el talibán es necesario Creo yo que
además es un Punto de partida para
establecer los diálogos intrafganos que
eso es otro gran problema si uno revisa
el acuerdo de doja de 2020 que
desarrolló el expresidente Trump con el
talibán queda claro que parte de este
acuerdo apuntaba a mirar a crear esos
relaciones y de diálogo entre las
diferentes fuerzas políticas del talibán
perdón de Afganistán incluyendo el
talibán el problema que que considero
aquí que que no se ha zanjado Es que la
constitución política que se regía en
Afganistán era desde el 2004 que se que
llega al talibán no funciona y que
tampoco se ha establecido el diálogo con
otras fuerzas y occidente entre una
llamada se terminó ha buscado poner
sobre la mesa unas fuerzas políticas que
gobernaron anteriormente Afganistán y
que están terminadas por actos de
corrupción y que por también razón
fueron retirados del poder paso a darle
la palabra a Andrés en la ciudad de
Madrid en este orden de ideas retomando
lo que dice Manuel quiero insistir en el
tema del reconocimiento porque creo que
es un punto importante
debe entonces la comunidad internacional
como lo dice acá mal llamada Manuel dar
ese paso dar ese reconocimiento con
algunas condiciones o primero sentarse a
dialogar con el talibán antes de dar un
reconocimiento cómo puede ser ese
proceso y que tanto puede jugar aquí el
talibán que tantos haces bajo la manga
tiene Andrés
no existe la comunidad internacional
como como se ha planteado existen
actores que compiten por la lucha por el
poder entonces evidentemente en el
momento unipolar sí que vimos que esa
comunidad internacional era en Estados
Unidos y sus aliados no importaba ahora
vemos que importa más y evidentemente
esos actores que importan más Rusia
china están tratando de que en ese juego
de ajedrez que son las relaciones
internacionales haya pequeñas trampas
porque la incoherencia occidental así
invita es decir que todos los
movimientos que haga occidente siguiendo
ese libro que ya no funciona sean
erróneos no hablar con los talibán como
acabamos de observar es un error Claro
porque evidentemente es el gobierno de
facto de Afganistán hablar con el
talibán también es un error porque
entonces desde el discurso hegemónico
liberal estarían cuestionando cómo es
posible que Naciones Unidas que es una
institución tan sana y saludable e
importante para los intereses del mundo
se reúna con un régimen que violan los
Derechos Humanos que no permite a las
niñas en las mujeres estudiar y
desarrollarse como seres humanos
entonces evidentemente lo que tenemos
que hacer es plantearnos el cambio de
libro el cambio de estructuras el cambio
de manera de hacer las cosas porque sino
obviamente
Rusia China y sus aliados tendrán una
oportunidad fantástica para poder atacar
todas las decisiones que occidente
también por supuesto mal llamado es
decir los países occidentales puedan
hacer en sus relaciones Bueno aparte el
debate ya tenemos dos dos términos aquí
que podemos también debatir y que
podemos replantear comunidad
internacional y occidente eso nos da
para un programa más adelante para
cerrar esta ronda Alejandro en la ciudad
de Buenos Aires su opinión
Mira básicamente lo que creo Es que se
corre el riesgo por esto mismo que decía
Andrés respecto de este occidente
incapaz y de esta comunidad
internacional que no es tal corremos el
riesgo de que el talibán vea la
oportunidad de utilizar el derecho de
las mujeres como un arma de retorsión O
sea extorsiva que ante la debilidad de
occidente lo que haga es para mejorar
sus posiciones de negociación hacer cada
vez las condiciones más duras eso la
única manera de evitarlo es que aquellas
potencias que tienen intereses en ese
lugar
se pongan de acuerdo respecto de cómo se
va a construir un diálogo serio y
racional y ese diálogo no puede excluir
a los propios protagonistas que tienen
el control real sobre el territorio
entonces creo que si no estamos como
dije al principio simplemente en una
puesta de escena para que se discuten
los medios y no hay ningún hecho en la
realidad Alejandro como estamos viendo
el panorama Tal parece que como dice el
dicho la pelota está del lado de la
cancha del talibán en este momento Ellos
tienen Tal vez un poco más de margen
para poner ciertas condiciones para una
posible negociación con organismos
internacionales o con otros países de la
comunidad internacional
qué tan afianzado está el talibán al
interior de Afganistán para tomar
decisiones que tanto respaldo pueden
tomar y tener estas decisiones al
interior de Afganistán y que tanto
margen de acción tienen ellos para
negociar con organismos internacionales
Mira el margen que ellos tienen no es
muy grande porque es una organización
que tiene principios muy rígidos
y convengamos que fue el resultado de
años y años de guerra contra la
intervención occidental entonces su
fortaleza se basa en haber triunfado en
una guerra contra un este una potencia o
un grupo de potencias una fuerza que se
había propuesto destruirlos y excluirlos
del país Entonces como toda fuerza
victoriosa tras una guerra goza de este
peso en la población No no es una cosa
que se va a poder hacer con voluntarismo
y buenas opiniones se requiere cierta
muñeca este habilidad política para
intervenir ahí y tal vez no tanto en los
medios y sí por líneas interiores ese
diálogo que se tiene que ser directo no
puede excluir a los países limítrofes y
obviamente a interés y Eso incluye a
China También
acá en el estudio France 24 Manuel su
opinión sobre este margen de acción del
talibán porque este talibán que estamos
viendo ahora que gobierna de facto
Afganistán es muy distinto al que estaba
en la época de los 80 90
Cuando regresaron a ocupar el territorio
cuando salieron las tropas de Estados
Unidos Vimos a unos representantes dando
entrevistas en inglés en medios
internacionales dando ruedas de prensas
y ya dejaron esa imagen de ser como un
grupo armado en zonas Rurales en las
montañas de Afganistán hoy en día es un
grupo más organizado es una formación
digamos política más formada más
organizada como sentía Sí yo lo
considero mucho más organizada con mayor
presencia en territorio y de hecho parte
del fracaso de Estados Unidos y sus
aliados en territorio afgano fue que
ellos se concentraron en la parte urbana
dejando de lado lo rural y allí También
digamos que los el talibán logró
organizarse y mantener su coherencia
digamos que parte del fracaso fue que la
el ejército afgano
apoyaba a Estados Unidos y aliados era
un ejército con muy muy ocupado o sea
muy equipado mejor equipado pero muy
dependiente de la otan y con altas tasas
de corrupción distinto cuando lo veíamos
en con los con el talibán que estaba en
la parte rural muy bien organizado e
ideológicamente muy fuerte en ese
sentido digamos que no hay que olvidar
que el digamos el talibán también ha
sacado de su territorio lo que se conoce
como Isis k y otras organizaciones y de
hecho el 25 de abril de este año el
talibán digamos asesinó a uno de los
líderes que estuvo en el atentado en La
retirada del ejército estadounidense y
aliados no entonces Creo yo que esa
legitimidad la ha ganado Y también si lo
miramos en el plano económico el alto
cobro de impuestos de hecho el talibán
lo ha mejorado lo ha vuelto más
eficiente y en ese sentido pues es con
lo que ha podido funcionar Con el poco
recurso que eso es lo que se le
dificulta actualmente por ejemplo el
presidente Joe biden solicitó que los 7
mil millones de dólares que tenía El
Banco Central afgano retenido en Estados
Unidos
fuese la mitad de eso hasta 3.700
millones dado a las víctimas del 911 del
atentado contra las Torres Gemelas y
esto pues claramente es un margen
también de acción del talibán diciendo
Mire yo he cumplido acá he sacado grupos
terroristas
el tema de Derechos Humanos claramente
no lo ha cumplido pero pues digamos que
también parte de su reivindicación es
que Estados Unidos no ha cumplido su
palabra en el sentido de devolver de su
dinero y que obviamente lo estás fixando
Entonces creo que esa parte tiene una
cierto margen de maniobra a nivel
internacional y en lo local claramente
su presencia que se fortaleció durante
la invasión y bueno dentro de la
permanencia de Estados Unidos y aliados
en Afganistán eso lo lo reforzó y esos
bloqueos internacionales por ejemplo en
este caso de las cuentas pues se va
reflejado en la economía afgana que está
sufriendo mucho y en la situación
humanitaria que se está viviendo allí
que es bastante difícil para los
habitantes Andrés en la ciudad de Madrid
quiero que un poco dentro del terreno de
lo que es Afganistán ya lo estamos
mencionando el talibán es un grupo muy
diferente el día de hoy pero qué hay de
el país como tal quién los apoya Quiénes
dan su voto por un por un talibán
gobernando ese país entendemos las la
situación que hay de derechos humanos y
la situación con las mujeres pero hay
que entender también que Afganistán es
un país que no es homogéneo es compuesto
por diferentes grupos tribales étnicos
lingüísticos es un país muy complejo
porque es prácticamente armado a la
fuerza Cómo mantiene el talibán esa
cohesión y ese apoyo en las diferentes
regiones
a través de la fuerza de La amenaza del
uso de la fuerza y de tener de que el
miedo sea el cemento que une a todos
esos grupos étnicos lingüísticos y
tribales que evidentemente ha sido la
forma en la que ha abro comillas
funcionado cierro comillas Afganistán en
los últimos miles de años no el tema es
que precisamente cuando mencionaba votos
y elecciones es precisamente ese sistema
que Estados Unidos y sus aliados
trataron de imponer en a partir del año
2001 que 20 años después ha aprobado que
es totalmente ineficaz porque los
aduanos nunca hicieron suyo ese modelo
muchas personas se beneficiaron de esa
financiación que Estados Unidos
principalmente estaba dando a ciertos
grupos de afganos sobre todo a través de
las instituciones que se intentaron
crear el ejército la policía y demás
instituciones ligadas al gobierno Y
entonces ha establecido ciertos grupos
de afganos que a través del cinismo
habitual de la zona se han enriquecido
pero evidentemente no ha cambiado ni la
mentalidad ni la forma de ver el mundo
ni la forma de organizar el país aunque
esto evidentemente no es nuevo ya decían
los romanos que cambian de cielo pero no
de espíritus los que cruzan Al otro lado
del mar y ya sabemos todos que hay una
cuestión que es la cultura y que la
cultura es difícilmente cambiar claro no
ha cambiado justamente esa cultura en
cuanto al trato a la mujer y a los
derechos a la mujer en Alejandro en la
ciudad de Buenos Aires hay mucha
indignación en la en la escena
internacional en torno a lo que sucede
con las mujeres en Afganistán lo hemos
tratado acá en France 24 en diferentes
programas lo hemos analizado desde
diferentes puntos pero qué va a pasar
entonces con las mujeres porque hay una
gran indignación a nivel internacional
Pero qué se está haciendo por ayudar las
verdaderamente o como se presiona
digámoslo así al talibán para tratar de
mejorar un poco la situación Por lo
menos mejorar la posibilidad de ir a a
formarse en una escuela y en una
universidad
el primer dato es que nosotros no
podemos y no se puede incluso muchos
países este que no formamos del de la
égida europea lo hemos sufrido no se
puede imponer un criterio
unívoco de cultura
hay valores universales pero que esos
valores universales tienen que convivir
con los valores regionales de la cultura
propia del lugar yo creo que la mejor
forma para que estos valores universales
convivan con estos valores particulares
es el diálogo si no hay una manera de
comunicarse de de construir confianza y
de que el talibán comprenda que ya no es
el talibán solamente sino el gobierno
constituido de un estado en un ámbito
donde hay otros estados y donde el
planeta Tiene ciertos consensos en los
cuales incluso puede participar
beneficiándose no va a haber manera la
forma es construir un diálogo donde vaya
encontrando el camino para lentamente no
al ritmo de los medios y del rating o de
las ong que presionan para tener una
política más dura con Afganistán sino
mediante un diálogo muy racional donde
ellos vean también beneficios no en
salir de esa situación este entre ellos
los este el acceso a sus fondos
congelados
y a mejoras que permiten incluso
mantener el control del país
pues cuando se tiene el monopolio del
uso de la fuerza y hoy este grupo que
controla el estado de Afganistán tiene
el monopolio del uso de la fuerza claro
y apunta de fuerzas que ha logrado
instaurar estas medidas y ha dejado
prácticamente en la esquina en el rincón
a las mujeres creo que por tiempo debo
cerrar acá el tema de analizar
rápidamente un breve panorama de cómo
está la situación interna de ese país
paso un poco hacer el análisis desde la
escena internacional y eso nos lleva a
entender una ecuación importante que
ustedes lo estaban planteando Y esa
ecuación involucra dos países muy
importantes en la región Pakistán y
China comienzo hablando con Manuela acá
en el estudio su opinión sobre los roles
que juegan estos países y que rol pueden
jugar en este acercamiento bueno juegan
un papel clave y cada país tiene un rol
sí Pakistán tiene un rol en el sentido
que el talibán también es una
organización política en el Pakistán en
Pakistán y en también tiene unas unos
intereses en Afganistán y es controlar
también grupos armados considerados
terroristas que atacan en suelo
pakistanico entonces hay un tema
seguridad que lo puede abordar Pakistán
Pakistán ya la semana anteriores se
reunió en Afganistán de hecho y hay un
compromiso frente a cómo limitar en
temas de seguridad el rol de China Creo
yo que es un rol más económico
Afganistán tiene muchos recursos
económicos bajo el suelo que por costos
Pues no ha podido poder extraer entonces
pueden tener tierras raras su principal
factor económico es el carbón pero
debajo de allí Pues hay mucho dinero
pero extraerlo te crearía maquinaria
pero también requeriría obviamente vía
férrea para sacarlo aquí china podría
jugar un papel clave en el sentido de
como lo decía mis anteriores colegas
poder crear diálogos y generarle
incentivos a los afganos para que haya
un compromiso de parte y parte y que
ellos también vean los beneficios de
poder integrarse en ello sí como la
economía global creo que china podría
jugar ese papel económico Pakistán de
seguridad y obviamente pues ahí
tendríamos que mirar como Naciones
Unidas también puede resolver el tema
político sí Pues digamos dentro de los
cuatro acuerdos cuatro puntos dentro del
acuerdo entre Estados Unidos y a los
afganos quedaba Claro que era un tema de
crear diálogos y hojas de ruta entre los
grupos políticos y yo coincido si no se
abre ese espacio va a ser muy difícil de
consolidar de consolidar digamos estos
acuerdos políticos y por último Yo creo
que es un tema fundamental el tema de
las mujeres aquí comúnmente se ha creído
que que con la intervención de Estados
Unidos las situaciones de las mujeres
mejoró y no despertadas cuando uno mira
las cifras de las mismas Naciones Unidas
del 2001 hasta el 2018 el 80% de las
mujeres seguían siendo analfabetas tan
solo el 13% son mujeres jueces y el 75%
de los matrimonios siguen siendo
forzados y Creo yo que aquí para mejorar
realmente la situación de Afganistán
Incluyendo a los afganos es también ser
sinceros con las cifras y los y las
propuestas que se puedan dar roles China
y Pakistán claramente juegan claves allí
me quedo con lo de la hoja de ruta y ahí
le pregunto a Andrés en la ciudad de
Madrid esa hoja de ruta puede empezar
tal vez a través de una mediación de
China como china ahora está jugando un
papel de mediador internacional ayudó a
ese acercamiento entre Irán y Arabia
Saudita ha tratado de hacer algunos
esfuerzos en la guerra en Ucrania con
una propuesta a Rusia de 12 puntos y
tratando de acercarse un poco al
gobierno de Ucrania o por lo menos
mostrándose así aquí china podría jugar
un papel mediador Más allá de los
intereses económicos
china es un país que tiene una frontera
terrestre con Afganistán
eso es crucial de entender y el tema
está en que a China no le interesa en
absoluto los intereses de Afganistán a
China le interesan los intereses de
China y China ya está extrayendo
recursos naturales en Afganistán porque
empresas chinas operan en Afganistán sin
tener necesidad de desplegar su aparato
de seguridad en Sololá gano ni de tener
que hacer ningún tipo de entrada
política en una situación tan compleja
como es las ranas de hecho el debate que
se está teniendo ahora mismo en las
relaciones internacionales chinas de los
académicos chinos que asesoran al
gobierno chino es precisamente en qué
momento china tendrá que empezar a jugar
un papel más destacado en esa
negociación Y esa forma de restablecer
el mundo a la manera China y ellos son
perfectamente conscientes que hacer esto
viene con un precio y es que cuando uno
no hace nada no comete errores por
acción y cuando uno algo por definición
comete errores entonces china ahora
mismo tiene un camino de nieve sin pisar
y quiere precisamente saber cuál es el
momento más adecuado para empezar a
hacer ciertos movimientos que por
supuesto No tendrán vuelta atrás y están
sujetos a que internacionalmente se
critica esa acción de China pero si
nosotros estamos planteándonos que china
va a poder ser un actor que busque una
justicia global una Justicia para todos
creo que no estamos en el camino
adecuado No no es el país para ese
escenario Alejandro en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires entiende uno entonces que
puede ser un país que se mueva En esa
dirección por los intereses que pueda
haber justo lo veíamos cuando salieron
las tropas de Estados Unidos y llegó
otra vez el talibán el primer país que
llegó a decirle al grupo talibán acá
estamos que hay para hacer
económicamente a nosotros no nos
interesa la situación política esas
críticas le han caído a China a lo largo
de los años por el relacionamiento que
tiene con algunos gobiernos africanos
asiáticos incluso latinoamericanos pero
china está ahí dispuesta a invertir a
cambio de tener ganancias es un gana y
gana y es una relación que ya pues creo
que el mundo aceptó Entonces el rol de
otro actor importante que no hemos
tocado acá Alejandro en la ciudad de
Buenos Aires el rol de Estados Unidos en
que quedó Estados Unidos en esta
ecuación y en su rol en Afganistán
después de la partida de las tropas
y ha quedado en un rol muy muy este
comprometido internacionalmente porque
él es gran responsable de lo que sucedió
en Afganistán con esa salida
intempestiva no planificada Y encima
dejando una enorme cantidad de material
para uso de uso militar para fortalecer
al talibán o sea también todos nos
preguntamos Hasta qué punto eso fue un
error fue impericia o están ocultando
mantener la región de manera inestable O
sea no es la primera vez que la
diplomacia norteamericana prefiere
mantener algo inestable a resolverlo
después de haber intervenido de manera
este siendo la fuerza principal de
intervención
creo que también Estados Unidos tendría
que hacerse cargo digamos del resultado
que obtuvo su intervención no porque la
situación actual como bien decían antes
digamos no no cambió nada sino que
empeoró la situación entonces hay una
tiene que haber una revisión de Cuál es
el rol que tiene Estados Unidos en este
tipo de intervención y y con ese con ese
panorama Manuel no cree usted que tal
vez y con tantos conflictos que hay en
este momento andando en el mundo del de
Ucrania que acapara absolutamente todo
este conflicto o esta disputa o este
reconocimiento no se desescalará dejarlo
simplemente como en algo regional que
aquí están ayude china ayude India de
pronto se involucre Irán o bueno Qatar
también que siempre ha jugado un rola
importante no Y la verdad no lo creo
desde la perspectiva de Washington
entendiendo lo que ustedes mencionaban
anteriormente china está jugando cada
vez más un rol importante en el Oriente
y ese terreno ganado por años no muy
bien ganado de Estados Unidos no lo va a
querer perder Entonces en ese sentido
creo que tampoco va a desescalar de yo
creo que lo que pasa en Ucrania también
va a tener alguna repercusiones en otras
regiones y obviamente el Afganistán No
no va no va a ser aislado de hecho y
comparto con la posición anterior a mi
intervención el tema de dejar ese
armamento de Incluso en los acuerdos se
quedó claro que Estados Unidos podía
apoyar al ejército afgano para poder
controlar a estos estas organizaciones
terroristas que quisieran utilizar suelo
afgano Entonces quiero que no va a dejar
de perder su importancia y mucho menos
en la medida que se ha comprobado que
Afganistán tiene litio que es un recurso
muy importante dentro del desarrollo de
las tecnologías hacia futuro y más y
como le decían anteriormente cercano a
china con un papel cada vez más
importante y que con una Rusia
debilitada en Ucrania pero que no hay
que olvidar que ese esa salida
progresiva a Estados Unidos de medio
oriente también le ha dado juego a los
rusos a pesar que ahorita están en este
conflicto pero también a los turcos
entonces creo que además esa relación de
ahora de Arabia Saudita con Irán dejando
un poco de lado a is creo que eso no va
a dejar de ser una prioridad también
para la casa blanca son piezas
importantes en esta rompecabezas
internacional me quedan ya unos cuantos
minutos para finalizar el programa como
son tres invitados quiero que empecemos
desde ya con las conclusiones para que
todos puedan hacer su redonde en el tema
de manera robusta comienzo entonces con
Andrés en la ciudad de Madrid que sigue
entonces para este país Cómo marcar esa
hoja de ruta Cuál va a ser el siguiente
capítulo que vamos a estar analizando un
encuentro entre las partes una
Afganistán simplemente dispersos sin
hacerle caso a las Naciones Unidas o un
gran esfuerzo en Naciones Unidas por
acercarse a dialogar con el talibán
No creo que Naciones Unidas tenga una
posición sobre Afganistán de hecho
Afganistán es un país miembro de las
Naciones Unidas Entonces
tenemos que darnos cuenta de la
complejidad de ese mundo que ya no va
hacia una sola música sino que hay
varias no creo que haya ninguna
intervención que cambie de facto la
situación creo que puede haber mucho
ruido puede haber muchas reuniones puede
dar muchas palabras pero no no soy nada
optimista sobre lo que puede ocurrir En
ese sentido yo creo que Afganistán
seguirá siendo como los países de su
categoría utilizado por las grandes
potencias para cumplir con los intereses
de las grandes potencias en este caso
además todo fracaso afgano es una
ganancia para los competidores de
Estados Unidos porque podrán presentar
Afganistán como un caso de estudio de
Qué pasa cuando seguimos la receta de
Estados Unidos y sus aliados en una zona
que desconocen y además siempre se podrá
vender
una Arista de que ha sido algo
planificado para que haya desorden
cuando mi hipótesis personal Es que es
por falta de capacidad no por un plan
muy desarrollado para destruir la
Y le doy la palabra entonces Alejandro
en Buenos Aires su conclusión que viene
para Afganistán
lo que viene para Afganistán es muchas
palabras de occidente y una acción
sistemática ordenada y que va a seguir
avanzando de China por los esfuerzos
simples que hace de establecer una
relación económica entonces Y
probablemente
India y Pakistán este nos podemos llegar
a encontrar en la situación en que se
estabilice esta relación y estos estos
países reconozcan el reingreso digamos
normal del talibán como legítimo de
Afganistán y en esa circunstancia
occidente va a tener que aceptarlo O sea
que no va a haber obtenido nada y va a
tener que aceptar a el ingreso de El
talibán como gobierno legítimo
Afganistán en la ONU claro y es que son
dos países muy fuertes en la región
China India disputan un rol privilegiado
en el continente asiático Emmanuel para
el cierre su conclusión y quiero que en
medio de este contexto de un sistema y
un orden internacional contestado creo
que Afganistán tiene la tal vez la
oportunidad de establecer de entablar
relaciones y comunicaciones con países
como lo usted bien lo decía China o la
India con el propósito de que su voz sea
incluida en que se abra una hoja de ruta
realmente en donde se establezcan los
diálogos dentro de Afganistán y no
solamente con estos fuerzas políticas
que occidente han apoyado sino con otras
facciones políticas que realmente
representen a los afganos y creo que
obviamente en medio de este
inconformismo de las políticas del
liberalismo internacional y Estados
Unidos creo que Afganistán si sabe
interpretar el contexto político y sabe
digamos gestionar su agenda política con
otros países creo que puede ayudar a
mejorar las condiciones de su población
y mirar cómo puede aumentar su
reconocimiento y con eso termino no hay
que olvidar que también no solamente hay
un contexto y contestas de contestación
a nivel internacional
sino también esos cambios geopolíticos
dentro de la región que también podrían
servirle para establecer por lo menos
como mínimo unos diálogos y una hoja de
ruta inicial pues se nos acaba el tiempo
Nos faltó tiempo para analizar la
situación de este país son muchas
aristas y muchos temas pendientes para
analizar pero dimos un panorama general
de lo que puede venir para este país a
Manuel Alejandro y Andrés les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros a ustedes
también Muchas gracias por la sintonía
En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos haber estado con nosotros el
día de hoy la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Andrés doncel y
Johanna galvis y la producción de
invitados a cargo de Tania Herrera
Pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]